Fran Lebowitz would the world be a
better place if we didn't have social
media yes
no expanding on that or even media right
no you're not you're not you're not
hooked in yet or app yeah and with or
who are what is the greatest untapped
resource for the children who are the
subject of your film love ya love from
not just people who are in their
immediate surroundings but people who
might want to come out of the confines
of their own home and and give some care
give some adult care everything shows
that children do best when there's an to
caring adult around doesn't have to be
their mother were there right I mean I'm
certainly not the authority never had
kids and I've arranged my life so I
never have to talk or be around a child
but I already just say once on airplanes
you watch children on airplanes or son I
avoid children and airplanes but if
somebody once said to me a kid just
needs one it doesn't have to be a real
parent and it doesn't have to be two you
have to have one person who matter what
you do to them they won't leave you know
that's right no rocks at them and
exactly right still be here tomorrow
exactly right that is established that's
probably gonna grow up to be a good
person that's right absolutely president
a fox are you concerned the Russia will
metal in the Mexican election but he has
always Merrill in Mexican elections so
we do our own game internally difficult
to have clear-cut transparent reliable
elections and here is happening the same
right it's not only them but it's also
the system you were with and the PRI
party was at the party no no no no that
that was no not you I'm saying that was
there for a long time right yes yes but
II please 71 years 71 years and then you
came along yes sir and what about to a
thousand and what about now
now we are living by democracy fortunate
it's very relative system and we have to
be very careful that it stays like that
right so that is it is really the winner
fully recognized okay
Salman ha as a writer how worried are
you about Trump attempting to curb
freedom of expression well I'm worried
I'm not terrified yet but but I'm but
I'm worried that you're faced worse you
know yeah I've been threatened by
professionals yeah I do think that
trying to undermine people's belief in
what they're hearing from the news media
is always the first step towards
totalitarianism because if somebody is
able to say don't believe them I am the
truth right that's how you get a
dictator right or a god or a god will
the religious right give Trump another
pass on his latest affair oh that's a
good question because how much does it
take now he's got a porn star and a
playmate while the wife is nursing it
just looks bad what would Jesus do well
yeah I mean you're asking me I don't
know if he would judge the sex part so
much but the lying part and the hurting
of the feelings part that I think he
would be a little harder on and Jesus
could be crabby they care about abortion
that's what they are so right that's all
they care about you know as long as they
got abortion illegal which is about to
happen that's what they care about
yes and they will be playing that card
when when this gets desperate you know I
know you think he's not gonna live out
that term I mean up at the Supreme Court
well the most important thing is Supreme
Court and that's why they voted them in
right and they don't care about the rest
of it right and they don't even believe
in that they never heard of sex before
and they're not gonna hear about it
but the thing they're really really
worried about is abortion because I
remember Barney Frank once saying the
Republicans only care about human life
from conception to birth it is amazing
that they're talking about abstinence
only with this particular president
they're trying to push abstinence this
man is the least godly least abstinent
man that was ever yeah
will Rob Porter and the shooting weed
law in the shooting we've lost with Rob
Porter in the show we've lost focus on
daca with the expiration date on March
5th is there any hope for resolution
daca well over a million young kids
deserved a solution they are part of
this nation they are extremely well
prepared and talented and he somebody
doesn't want him here we would love to
have them in Mexico but I I have to
respect that they are from this nation
they love this nation and they want to
stay here and they deserve that
happening in we will never exchange one
person for $1 for the wall no [ __ ]
whoa
[Applause]